this shows inflation over the last two
years soaring to more than 10 percent
that's sooner than economists had
predicted and now five times above the
bank of england's two percent target
inflation is now in double digits
reaching a 40-year high the highest
since february 1982 which means most
working adults will never have known
inflation like this
now this chart explains what's driving
the increase the top bar shows the
biggest contributor is food and
non-alcoholic drinks along with
household services and also recreation
and culture activities that's things
like days outs and package holidays the
typical things we do in the summer
if we look specifically at food and
drink prices here have continued to rise
between june and july there was an
increase of 2.3
taking the annual inflation rate to
12.7 to july
now in terms of which foods are driving
the increase it's the basics milk is up
34
butter up 27 pastas there eggs up 14
and bread 11
but the biggest annual driver is still
energy look here gas has risen by
95.7 electricity by 54
and come october when off gem increases
the fuel price cap again which experts
predict will be by about 80
the fear is inflation will go up to 13
let me just show you one more chart this
analysis by sky news shows that even by
the beginning of this year a gap was
opening up meaning that those on the
lowest incomes are being hardest hit it
shows how inflation is getting higher
for poorer households compared with
better off households that's because as
a share of their total spending lower
income households spend more on energy
and with october's price cap hike
this gap will grow even wider